it's already been a tough few weeks and
the relations between the U.S and North
Korea for the first time since the 80s a
U.S nuclear-armed ballistic missile
submarine docked at a South Korean port
and North Korea launched two more
missiles into the sea and now a surprise
defection Army private second-class
Travis King in the Army for just over
two years and without combat experience
is believed to have bolted across the
border separating the two countries and
was taken into North Korean custody it's
believed he was just released from a
South Korean prison on assault charges
brought to the airport to be sent home
to potentially face additional charges
and likely be kicked out of the army it
seems he was escorted to customs and
then got away with a tour group headed
to the Border we're closely monitoring
and investigating the situation
and working to notify the soldiers next
to Kin
and engaging to address this incident in
terms of my concerns I'm I'm absolutely
foremost concerned about the welfare of
our troop North Korean experts believe
the soldier will be tortured it is very
likely that he will be subjected to
harsh treatment especially since he's a
member of of the U.S armed forces
so that the likelihood that he will be
tortured he will face psychological
pressure he will face a physical torture
the likelihood of that happening is very
high now the focus on how to get him
back they can use this as a bargaining
chip and say well you know if you want
him back you're going to have to take
more troops out of South Korea or get
rid of this nuclear you know
consultative group something like that
because obviously they have the upper
hand we care about our men and women who
serve in the past U.S administrations
have refused to take those steps for
fear it will encourage more Americans
being arrested but they have done
prisoner swaps scenarios likely being
considered in Washington as they wait
and wonder what is happening to their
soldier who tried to get away Patty
culhane Al Jazeera Washington
Robert Kelly is a professor of political
science and diplomacy at the rusan
National University he says North Korea
will likely demand concessions from the
U.S for the return of the soldier
every two or three years you get some
guy who sort of like runs across a
bridge somewhere and these kinds of
things happen you get sort of weird
people who have weird ideas about North
Korea you know they read too much
Twitter or whatever or they watch the
Youtube videos and they run in there
this has been sort of a running problem
for a while and in fact the U.S state
Department advises American citizens not
to travel to North Korea anymore I went
to North Korea myself about 10 years ago
and I would not go back at this point I
think it's too dangerous I live here in
South Korea and this is something most
of the Americans I know here wouldn't go
I think there's a kind of general
interest right there's a there's kind of
a strange interest to see what North
Korea is like but I think it's pretty
widely understood now that it's too
risky so with this guy I mean we just
don't know if I had to guess it's
probably got some kind of mental issues
or something like that or he can read
some really weird stuff or saw something
on social media but there are ways the
US and North Korea talk to each other
through the U.N and stuff like that and
through third parties and stuff like
that and my guess is right again you
know we don't know all the stuff sort of
closed doors but my guess is right now
the defense department is sort of like
talking to the North Koreans through
various counterparties perhaps the
Chinese or something like that trying to
find out first of all what happened like
like is this guy okay I mean he's he
mentally ill and like what is his deal
because it's pretty bizarre that you
would like run across the border like
that right um so I think there's gonna
be some of that and then basically we're
gonna have to find out what the North
Koreans want and again my guess is the
North Koreans are bringing back normally
the North Koreans sit in these kinds of
people for like six months or something
like that and they extract a bunch of
concessions they put them on TV and they
talk about how you know they're
defeating the American colonialists or
something like that but then eventually
they sort of get they do get rotated
back and there's some kind of swap you
know some you know money or something
like that on the side